et on poursuit cette page loisir avec
vos idées de sortie Gabriel quel est le
programme pour ce weekend de Noël et
bien j- 3 avant Noël Régine et plusieurs
sorties ont retenu mon attention pour ce
weekend on commence avec un concert
unique au château de Versailles pour le
25 décembre l'auteur compositeur
Jean-Michel jar investit la célèbre
galerie des Glaces je vous parleris d'un
concert unique pourquoi car il s'agit
d'un concert immersif ceux qui ne
pourront pas assister physiquement
pourront le découvrir dans le méavert
grâce à une collection en réalité
virtuelle dans ce spectacle le musicien
rendra hommage aux grandes fêtes royales
mais aussi aux innovation technologique
on regarde un extrait de la bande
[Musique]
annonce
au total c'est 600 spectateurs qui sont
attendus en physique et pour ceux Régine
qui veulent y assister à distance et qui
sont moins à l'aise avec le métaverse
rendez-vous sur W9 où le concert sera
retransmis en tout cas de quoi danser
toute la soirée du 25 décembre et même
potentiellement de redécouvrir la
galerie des glaces ou toute une autre
une autre forme alors on part maintenant
direction rambouillé ou un autre
rendez-vous nous attend ce weekend oui
ça se passe au musée ramboli train vous
qui vous propose un voyage de Noël pour
le 23 décembre au programme de ces
animations festives compte de Noël suivi
d'une visite du musée une plongée dans
le monde du train miniature qui pourrait
aider les petits et les grands à
patienter encore un peu jusqu'au soir de
Noël à noter également que les 27 et 28
décembrees ainsi que les 3 et 4 janvier
le musée vous propose de monter à bord
de son train de jardin spécial Noël de
quoi prolonger les fêtes exactement et
une autre activité de saison pourrait
également faire patienter avant le
réveillon plusieurs patinoirs vous
ouvrent leurs porte en ce moment oui en
intérieur ou en extérieur plusieurs
communes ont installé des patinoires
pour les fêtes en voici une liste non
exhaustive aux clés sous-bois vous
pouvez chausser vos patins dans l'espace
Philippe Noiré où une patinoire est
installée jusqu'au 6 janvier à trrape
c'est une patinoire de 204 8 m 288 m²
qui vous attend jusqu'au 5 janvier avec
plusieurs soirées à thème proposé pour
les familles ou encore pour les ados
enfin cette année encore une patinoire
extérieure vous attend dans votre centre
commercial de l'espace 5 Quentin elle
est accessible jusqu'au 6 janvier et des
samedis le château de Breteuil propose
lu aussi des animations pour les fêtes
de fin d'année si vous souhaitez
découvrir ou redécouvrir le château de
Breteuil c'est le moment Régine pour les
fêtes le monument à revêti ses plus
belles décorations sapin table de fête
ou encore façade et jardin illuminé le
château des conttes de Péro et fééic en
plus des visites commentées des comptes
de Noël seront proposés ce weekend et on
termine avec un parcours d'art lumineux
à Mantel jolie oui que diriez-vous de
redécouvrir la ville illuminée c'est en
tout cas l'objectif de l'événement lueur
de manthe dans un parcours au travers de
la commune la ville de manth la jolie
vous propose une vis nocturne de son
patrimoine illuminé de scénographie
lumineuse et d'œuvr d'art numérique pour
réaliser ses installations des artistes
nationaux et internationaux ont été
réunis parmi les lieux à découvrir
l'incontournable collégial bien sûr mais
aussi l'hôtel de ville ou encore la
place du marché au blé vous avez
jusqu'au 10 février 2024 pour profiter
du spectacle bien merci Gabriel vous
avez une préférence pour ce weekend le
concert à la galerie d'gas je pense que
ça peut être sympa très original moi je
dirais plutôt la ptinoire ça fait un
petit moment que j'ai pas testé
j'aimerais bien voir ce que je VO